I am in the language department and
Chapters Indigo bookstore to see what I
can find in the way of something to help
me with my Ukrainians is we don't have
Ukrainian link so what are they up here
we have the usual yes l type of stuff
foreign languages Spanish
let me just see what I can find
walking down the Pacific Mall I tried to
film myself buying a book on your
cranium was told I was about to take
pictures or videos in the bookstore so
now I'm in the mall here and work out to
my Korea and Canadian businessman
whatever there's another person filming
in front of me that I go and you know
when you think about it here I bought
this book now I like buying books but
teach yourself Ukrainian with my
discounted chapters is sixty million
dollars anyway more on that later before
I crash into someone
well here I am back home I only stayed
there for about an hour and a half some
comments first of all you only saw about
five six seconds of that party I tried
to do a selfie me talking to people in
Korean and when I looked at the video is
just so noisy it sounds like a lot of
people fighting in there I think I'll
have to I'll have to get myself a little
microphone that can isolate all the
other people saw that I can do one of
those so just to give you a bit of a
flavor but there was nothing worth
showing you there um completely Ukranian
of course it's never very complete but
with this and then with copying and
pasting bits and pieces from Ukrainian
newspapers into Google Translate and
translating into Russian or English and
then watching my Ukrainian TV I think
I'll be out but with my Ukrainian pretty
quickly Korean no that's the challenge
and I said I had 28 days I don't I have
18 or 17 days here so I gotta get a move
on a couple of things that happen today
I had one of my transcribers do another
podcast not on literature but on
politics there's a lot of dialogue in it
I haven't gone through linking so I
listen to it on my way to the evening of
the Korean Canadian businessman
Association it sounds really good so I'm
gonna be doing some of that the party I
did well okay so here I think the
important thing is that context is so
important in language learning context
in so many different ways
I learned better from context that's of
interest to me I do better when I have a
comfortable context with people that I'm
comfortable with and when I'm talking
about things that are meaningful to me
and familiar so when I was being
interviewed about our project about link
and so forth two three weeks ago I did
find when I had to phone when I was on
the phone here with this purse
we were talking about a number of things
having to do with you might buy some
advertising in their newspaper this is
the newspaper that interviewed me and
you're on the phone you don't know what
the other person is doing maybe they're
in a hurry and and in that kind of an
environment it's difficult that context
is so much more difficult you feel you
feel a bit challenged it's like when I
like Russian I have had you know
conversations with our tutors in Lincoln
so many subjects I go to Russia go to
the train station and there's a lineup
and when it finally comes my turn and
there's people behind me and the lady
there goes little bit and I don't know
what she's saying I've got to buy a
ticket to go to the Borg whatever it is
I lost it there or similarly when I was
in that restaurant and I wasn't quite
anticipating what the Korean waitress
would say and there's so much background
noise however there was background noise
at this party lots of background noise
but I was with people who were friendly
towards me who had nothing else to do
but listen to me and were willing to
listen to me in Korean and helped me and
so that was a very friendly reassuring
environment and I thought I did their
best I can I that I've ever done in
Korean I was speaking lots of Korean and
and doing fine mind you in that kind of
a setting I said what we're gonna talk
about to a large extent and they're
gonna ask things like you know how long
have you been studying Korean and blah
blah blah stuff this that I'm kind of
comfortable talking about although we
did stray away from that a bit so I
guess the important thing is context
context in terms of what we study
context in terms of the the context of
what we're talking about who we're with
the atmosphere may be having a beer
helped I don't know
context matters so while I'm gonna be
doing some work Ukrainian so I can
follow what's happening by the way I
gather that as a result of Larionov
having met with John Kerry in Amsterdam
then as a result Putin has phoned Obama
I even see Lukashenko here saying he's
the president of Belarus he wants to get
involved and help out so maybe just a
lot of brinksmanship on the part of the
Russians a lot of sabre-rattling to
achieve whatever they want to achieve in
Ukraine
and things are gonna maybe deescalate
here we hope time will tell so context
in language learning is very important I
am gonna stay focused on Korean but I am
still gonna sneak over there oh and I
wanted to comment on this I had to buy
this stupid thing because they don't
just sell the book I only want the book
I have to buy the 2 CDs it's gonna be
very but maybe it'll be good but it's
$60 for a little beginner book like this
and at the end of which you are nowhere
and I think it's worth it I think it's
worth it and then I walk through that
mall and I see all got junk in that mall
you know clothing stores in this kind of
store and I see nothing there that I
would like to buy nothing there that I
need I see this book so I mean people
say they can't spend ten dollars a month
that link you know I mean by a year
package it's I mean it's limitless
content it's a lot more than you get in
this book but people will spend money
and I mean those are ordinary people
walking through that mall buying stuff
people will spend on all kinds of junk
they don't want to spend on language and
yet I think language is so much more
rewarding but then everybody has their
own tastes and interests and things that
make them happy so we should all we
should all do the things that make us
happy where we can bye for now